one of the reasons that i try to come up
with unifying explanations is that
you know if you look at the number of
wildfires in california let's say that
we've just seen
if you treat them all as spontaneous
uncorrelated
uh instances it feels like oh my god
it's just whack-a-mole every time i
send a fire truck here there's a fire
over there so you want to come up with
something like a central theory which is
why do i suddenly have a problem when i
hadn't had
a problem before so i look for these
unifying explanations and i i found one
the other day that really speaks to me
um i mean people are very frustrated
because they've been trained to think
about this
incorrectly in my opinion but here's the
graph
that you need to look at on the x-axis
is time by year
and on the y-axis is something like
average age
of a human the title of the graph is any
desirable situation involving
institutions
so that could be ceo it could be tenured
professor
it could be who's getting grants
it could be the age at which people win
nobel prizes
university presidents all these things
go up
in other words for a long period of time
the average
age of the person in a desirable
situation has been increasing
something like nine months for every 12.
those graphs have to go down at some
point the specter of
billionaire of having five people all
born in the 1940s as the final
entrance in the presidential context
that makes no sense think about how
bizarre
a thing that nobody's even really
talking about the last five
people were all ancient
by presidential standards not one not
two but
five we are talking about a contest
between somebody who is the oldest of
the baby boomers
the very beginning of the baby boom
summer of 46th birthday
fighting somebody who is in the silent
generation
the silent generation guy in a town hall
in florida
gets this question from a gen z guy
saying you know
what what's going on with my future joe
biden has the
um audacity to say i'm a transitional
president
you guys the highly educated one when
has any generation in history needed a
transitional
78 year old person to take office it's
bizarre it's preposterous
that graph is the graph we can't talk
about
that graph is the graph of our
destruction
because it has the you can make a
one-line argument which is
sounds like ageism which isn't a very
good argument
no but what it does is is it it muddles
the conversation
and you always have to ask yourself the
question if this conversation becomes
muddled who wins as a result of the
muddling
well it's a battle but so we let's just
win it let's win the battle
you give are you running for sure
i'll run i was born in russia you can't
run so uh
but we russians can hack elections so
we'll figure it out
uh this is me officially announcing my
run i was born in st
petersburg florida
yeah lex what is it that you really want
to ask i think
i want to put some responsibility on the
portal the portal
the portal that the portal gives
power to the people in that graph
like because you you put it quite
brilliantly that the people that
moved the world their age has been going
up
and not moved the world but put in the
position where they get the chance
to affect the world the
these new platforms i think twitter
falls in
in them give power to the younger people
it doesn't have to be about asia
necessarily but the younger thinking
people
so that's a promising thing and you
are like you're like gandalf you get to
you get to pick your frodos
or whatever i'm not very good with the
the analogy but the whole point is for
us gandalf i don't know that i make that
much sense
gandalf makes sense i don't know if
people
know how to fit me into this ecosystem
i think there's something in my
presentation that people find very
confusing no figure it out i'm not i
disagree with you but you need to look
at the mirror and think like what
what is it is it um maybe you need a
mustache
i don't know but there's something about
figuring out um how to be a charismatic
communicator in this and that that's the
responsibility you said like
finishing sentences with the lol is
painful for your soul
yeah that's just how somebody lets me
know i don't have to take their opinion
seriously
yeah it's still the language the the way
that people are communicating and you're
swimming that way if you have a big
platform
i have a growing platform it feels like
this is the place to give
i agree i agree but we're going to get
swatted now i just don't think so
you're wrong why are you afraid of the
big like this is i've studied it
you